how are you ad I'm doing well rich how
are you well we're having a conversation
about whether Matthew Stafford's worth
the money and to reboot for five more
years at the freight that the lines have
paid I say yes Chris Brockman says he's
already reached his ceiling and that's
the end of that what do you say well
I'll say this Matthew Stafford had
arguably the greatest weapon of all time
offensively and Calvin Johnson and still
couldn't win a playoff game that's tough
to deal with
anytime you pay a person a hundred
million dollars you either have to draft
really well and put a ton of talent
around them or you'll end up like the
Baltimore Ravens where they've kind of
messed up on the draft and they haven't
had money to pay for agents and pay guys
so it kind of straps your team a little
bit but the way the salary caps are
structured and the way the TD money is
coming in you're gonna see guys starting
to get those 90 million dollar contracts
because the timings right and so kudos
to Matthew Stafford I mean that's always
awesome I'm always for players getting
paid you know I've always you know Dion
always says show me the money so he
definitely got that but again is it for
the team's sake it's gonna be tough to
win right now if they don't win in the
near future it's gonna be tough to win
because you're gonna have some guys that
are gonna want some cash and I could be
able to pay up well what's the
alternative you know I mean the
alternative would be to let matthew
stafford walk for compensatory picks or
two in this offseason to have traded
before age 29 and try and get something
and then reboot in detroit I mean what
what is the other alternative Maurice
you know and I think that's the issue
the teams have Matthew Stafford was the
number one overall pick and so you know
he's kind of timings been perfect where
you know Derek Carr comes in the Raiders
are similar to where the Seattle was
when they could you know kind of build
around their car because he was a
second-round pick and they didn't have
to pay him so much money so they're able
to pay some other guys that often
supplied it put some pieces around him
so you get a mari Cooper and things like
that for Detroit um you know it's hard
for them to do that because they're
always in the middle of the the rankings
so they're all
xviii picking the drafts are always xx
picking the drafts of 22 and it's tough
to get those Amari Cooper type players
or big-time players I just think you
know you have to do it as a team because
you want that you know if you don't have
a quarterback you're definitely not
going to win but you know sometimes
we're starting to see these quarterbacks
who aren't Tom Brady Aaron Rodgers Big
Ben who have won the big game and it
played well get paid crazy and it's
gonna be hard to put players around them
well I mean and you could also say
Maurice jones-drew joining me here
though is the three guys you just
mentioned though have got a stable
long-term successful franchises that
don't change quarterbacks they do I mean
don't change coaches don't change
general managers don't change
philosophies they know who they are and
they keep going with it and that you
could say if Stafford got drafted
somehow by the Steelers or Packers
something would be different right
correct well I definitely think so I
think it would be different but I still
feel like when you spend that type of
money on one player you're you're
allocating so much money of your cap to
one guy that he has to be able to cover
up some of your deficiencies
I don't think Matthew Stafford could do
that I think he's a top-ten quarterback
in the league yes
but you know those top four guys five
guys like Drew Brees they can cover up a
lot of issues that you have now we're
starting to see Drew Brees
in the stance where he can't cover up
all those issues you can't out score
everybody anymore like they're used to
doing in New Orleans and so they've had
to spend money on helping them out
fixing that defense and trading guys and
trying to get extra picks and trying to
take care of both sides of the ball so I
just feel like just because he's a
top-10 guy you know for the team's sake
he has to know I've been the day rich he
has to be able to make plays and so when
you get these 92 million dollars
guaranteed and you get these uh you know
135 million dollar contract extension
you're gonna have to cover up a lot like
that offensive line is not going to be
as good and those receivers aren't going
to be as good all those type of things
so Maurice jones-drew of the NFL Network
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
so what situation would you rather have
a situation with the Lions where you've
got a 29 year old who's racked up the
yards and has proven he can be a
prolific passer in this league but is
now gonna take up one sixth of your
salary cap for a team that hasn't won in
a long time or would you rather have the
jaguars where you got year four of
somebody who's gonna be making 19
million dollars next year who cuz you're
already on the hook for it if certainly
if he gets hurt and you don't even know
if Blake bortles is the guy and you're
just hoping cuz that there's no other
option which which would you rather have
anyways yeah I mean I feel like both are
they're kind of different
I would prefer and this is just me on my
per I would prefer the jaguars because
they have more pieces around with Blake
bortles you can cut them and you're also
I think you're off the hook for but
majority of that 19 not all of it but if
you cut them in these you cut them for
skill and not injury then you're off the
hook and you can get another guy and
they have pieces around and you talk
about they have Allen Robinson Allen
Hurns they have marquise Lee we've seen
some of the young guys like Dede
Westbrook they have winner for ness they
have pieces around there also the line
needs to continue to get better
understand but you know that they've
done a great job with the way they built
that deeper so they have things that
kind of go around they just need that
last piece that quarterback to be the
guy where I think there's more building
on Detroit side and it's going to be
hard to do that when you have like you
said one six of your tap committed to
one person I mean that's that is like
when I saw this contract yes I think was
yesterday right that it came across yes
sir yes I was I was baffled I felt like
you know I'm doing my kids a disservice
we all need to play quarterback play
quarterback
forget offensive lines forget wide
receiver everybody plays quarterback or
left-handed pitcher left-handed pitcher
that would be bad or or yeah I mean
there's you ting guard I get that I
there's certain positions that are going
to get paid a lot of money we understand
that but you have to do it in reason
it's just right now like and cook like I
said kudos to Matthew Stafford because
that's a phenomenal contract but at the
end the day quarterbacks are graded off
of wins and losses you can throw for
6,000 yards
and a hundred touchdowns but if you're
you know nine and seven what good is
that you don't make the playoffs I think
those are the issues with quarterbacks
and that's why it's so hard I was a you
put did you put a stat out there
yesterday on Twitter saying that uh was
it like the top five paid quarterback
yeah I have a record of like nine and
thirteen in the play 19 in the playoffs
that is crazy and takes your Brees out
in it's three knee that is correct
exactly like so so we're like are you
I'm trying to figure out what what are
we paying for we play well you Peter do
you feel like what you're paying for
Maurice is the fact that that over the
next five years Stafford is gonna throw
four on average 20,000 yards combined
you got that handled let's figure out
the rest of it and go to battle and with
all due respect you know other teams
like Jacksonville most of the other
league is still stumbling around for a
guy who could try and put 20,000 yards
together over five years the the Rams
are on there you know on their knees
every night hoping that golf turns into
somebody like that you're seeing him in
person how does how does he look right
now well JD he's not gonna he's not
gonna die and I'm glad you like said
cause your Golf is not gonna throw the
20,000 yards that's not what their
offense is built for they've they have a
guy that is I feel I can be a step above
Alex Smith a guy who can manage the game
eventually you would want him to turn
into a game changer but right now how is
how he started he didn't start like dak
Prescott he didn't start like Carson
Wentz he started obviously in a
different situation but you have a guy
who right now has taken tremendous
strides from last year he's gotten
gotten better but he has more command of
the offense he's not turned the ball
over I want to say you through a couple
picks or a pick against the Chargers
after getting a little pressure in his
face and things like that but this guy
has gotten better so you you've added
pieces around him like Sammy Watkins and
Robert woods Cooper Cup and then Todd
Gurley and you had Andrew Whitworth to
protect them and you allow him to grow
in that in that way I think he will be
eventually he may not be Matthew
Stafford with the numbers but I think
he'll be
more of Alex Smith with the wind where
they're winning 11 11 games a year 10 11
game them you could you can mark that up
with the Chiefs every year well but
isn't he playing in an offense that's
helped make Kirk Cousins one of those
top five paid quarterbacks in the league
Maurice he so so and I'm glad you
brought that up Kirk cousin I think
again they're very similar Kirk Cousins
we saw last year he had tremendous
weapons around him and that's what this
offensive system is about it's about
more of the weapons in the quarterback
where the quarterback is his job is to
get the ball out quickly get it to his
weapons let his weapons make plays in
space every now and then take a shot but
make sure it's a calculated shot it's
not one of those you're just who's the
guy that likes to throw the ball up just
toss it up well I mean Matthews happened
to do that to Calvin Johnson all the
time right throw it up in the air and
then hopefully Calvin had come down with
three people around them this office
didn't built that way it's built more of
being having calculated you know just
calculated shots and so I think Jarrod's
still learning how to play the
quarterback what people don't remember
they don't know is you know enrich
you've been around Lucian and Kurt
Warner Jerrod golfing has never before
that last year never took a snap under
center and never called a play in the
huddle it's when you have to reteach
those things that we all learn and use
football or pop order no I hear you man
20 and then I just used to bring this
full circle before I let you go it's
just I'd rather be in this the lion
situation where I'm paying my sixth I'm
paying one six to a guy that I'm not I'm
not trying to hope in the next 2-3 years
blossoms into somebody who can throw a
prolific amount of yards in this league
and I'm not worried about whether he's
called plays in a huddle and under
Center and stuff like that I mean why
would you want to go back to that if you
already have emotionally and and
literally invested in somebody like
Stafford well I think I think Detroit is
different you know you know what
Stafford is you've had it for eight
years he's not going to change who he is
I just think it's the same way where the
the Chiefs kind of drafted uh the guys
mahomes they know who alex smith is and
he gets him to the playoffs every year
he ended that drought where they won
their first game but they don't feel
like he can get him over the hump
and so they're gonna keep them and
they're gonna train Mahone's for the
next two or three years but they feel
like my homes is gonna be more of that
guy that can get them he's gonna take
those chances and help get them over the
hump yeah it's weird to say that I think
Cincinnati's in the same situation where
they were a team that was so used to
losing all of a sudden after winning
four or five years in a row is like okay
and Andy Dalton can get it to the big
game we need a new quarterback for me
similar to Detroit you know what you're
doing you have a guy but now you have to
build around this guy how can you build
a round up how can you pay some
defenders to come in when it's gonna be
usually strapped with cap that's that's
really good it comes down to he's taking
up so much money it's gonna be hard to
build a team around him that's all MJ
deep love the chat well chat again soon
we'll see you soon yes I can't wait I
can't wait to see you in person too rich
right back at you at M JD this is new
Twitter handle I like that oh he got rid
of the Jones underscore drew thirty-two
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy